Attention ! J'ai fait une découverte de fou dans ma vie.
Une petite vidéo très différente de tous mes sketchs, de tous mes court-métrages.
Voila, y'a pas une équipe de 10 personnes avec des semaines d'écriture et de préparation.
C'est une vidéo toute simple pour vous parler d'un truc qui m'a rendu fou.
Je me baladais, comme ça, tranquillement sur Instagram. Et y'a des gens,
qui peuvent te taguer, vous savez ça. C'est souvent des selfies, que je prends avec des gens
en dédicace ou dans la rue je sais pas quoi bref, y a ma gueule sur les trucs
on me tague dessus ça parait presque normal. Sauf que
je vois une vidéo d'une meuf qui m'a taguée dessus. Un jour plus tard, deux jours plus tard
les jours passent et je vois de plus en plus de vidéos comme ça
de gens qui me taguent sauf que je vois bien que sur la vidéo ce n'est pas moi!
Qui sont ces gens qui me taguent dessus ?! Je ne sais pas! Un jour je décide de cliquer
et là qu'est ce que je vois? Ma voix sur le corps de quelqu'un d'autre.
"Alors oui j'ai choisi Allemand LV1, j'ai pas trop compris pourquoi mais
je comprends encore moins ceux qui choisissent d'apprendre une langue
qui n'existe plus" ... Mais c'est incroyable!
J'en parle autour de moi, à des potes
Putain y'a des gens ils reprennent mes vidéos
mais ils en refont les images
c'est rigolo etc. On me dit: Bah oui c'est Tik Tok.
Partez du principe que je suis une personne âgée donc
j'avais entendu parler de Tik Tok hein mais j'ai repoussé le moment où je devais créer un compte.
Je fais "ok Tik Tok j'en ai entendu parler, qu'est ce qu'il se passe dessus ?"
Je crée un compte!
C'est parti entrons dans Tik Tok !
Et c'est là
Où le truc est devenu fou c'est que je vais sur Tik Tok,
je cherche Cy-pri-en
et là qu'est ce que je vois, des gens qui reprennent mes vidéos sur tik tok
ça a fait 26 millions de vues
j'en avais jamais entendu parler ! C'est incroyable! Bon concept absolument incroyable sur cette vidéo
Et bah on va découvrir toutes ces vidéos que vous avez fait sur moi, c'est parti !
"l'espion il snap tout le temps sans prévenir en "scred"
Tu fais un snap là ? Non... Mais tu préviens quand
tu fais un snap, c'est tout, tu fais pas ça en "scred"!
C'est génial! Ils connaissent mieux le sketch que moi… Je l'ai fait qu'une seule fois. Eux là ça se voit
que ça été répété. Ça me fait extrêmement plaisir.
Et surtout de voir des gens, surtout des filles, avec ma voix
C'est très perturbant. Ça mérite un petit like… "Anglais, excuse moi deux secondes
Euh, pour la conjugaison du verbe être… " Putain, mais c'est la même chose.
" Juste pour savoir. Bah c'est I am " Putain c'est génial !
"Et ensuite bah c'est la même chose… You are, we are, they are..."
" Sous le C j'ai mis une petite couille.
Une petite couille?!" Alors ça énorme, une fille
avec ma voix qui dit "Une petite couille?!" J'adore, on se le remet une fois.
" Une petite couille?!" C'est liké. On est d'accord que c'est 95% de filles.
Peut-être que les mecs qui font des vidéos d'autres (personnes)
Moi, y'a que les filles qui sont autorisées à refaire mes vidéos, je ne sais pas.
" J'ai un métier un petit peu particulier, un métier qui n'existait pas y'a quelques années…
Je suis auteur, comédien, réalisateur, monteur, producteur de vidéos
Sur internet. Ouais, t'es youtubeur quoi. Ouais voilà, c'est ça, je suis youtubeur. Auteur, comédien… "
"Réalisateur..." *rire*
Franchement, je suis très flatté.
Je sais qu'il y a des gens qui regardent et je vois juste
les commentaires et tout ça. Mais voir que les gens les connaissent par cœur
Ça me fait extrêmement plaisir. Merci à tous, tous ces gens là qui
refont des… Oulala… Oulala... Ça ne s'arrêtera jamais!
Où est la fin?!! Et j'aime bien la petite surprise de je ne sais pas quel sketch ils vont reprendre
"What a surprise, we Don't know " Y'a un truc qui m'insupporte …
Quand t'apprends une langue, c'est les mecs qui se foutent de ta gueule parce que …
Tu t'es un peu trompé en parlant… Pff, il a dit la canapé
au lieu de le canapé!" Je trouve ça super expressif, je trouve ça fou…
" Tuez-vous!! Mettez des oursins dans votre slip…
y'a pas de blague" Wouah, c'est génial! Franchement…
Mr Comédie liké comme jamais… "Moi mon médecin il est un peu chelou…
Tu sais, il parle en baragouinant" Génial, donc ça
C'est carrément une vidéo de Norman *rires*
y'a quand même écrit #comédie #France #humour #Cyprien #médecin #youtube
Cette personne n'a jamais regardé mes vidéos car c'est Norman je n'ai pas fait de vidéo sur les médecins.
"Quand je vois les nouveaux trucs qui sortent par exemple les écouteurs ...
sans fil (180 balles; merci apple) je me dis ma grand-mère elle doit être totalement paumée
*rire* pas mal les filles sont jumelles donc elles se disent on va faire à deux la voix
comme ça c'est tout aussi claire, autant se redonner
différents rôles, mais là elles se disent nan nan mais attend mais on le fait en même temps
tu fais toi ou je fais moi *leee* quand il parle Cyprien et ben on le fait toutes les deux
*mmmmm* malin. "Grand-mère: qu'est que tu cherches ? Cyprien: euh mes écouteurs ils étaient là.
Grand-mère: Oh c'est bon, c'est bon, je m'en suis occupée. Cyprien : de mes écouteurs?" Comment faire une grand-mère
les draps, les draps du matelas et un peu de maquillage
mais je devrais faire ça, c'est bon je suis une grand-mère ou pas ? Je pense que je suis une grand-mère maintenant
les gens ne feront pas la différence j'ai dupé les plus grands.
Je suis un génie du déguisement. "Le prof qui a perdu les devoirs mais qui veut pas le dire"
le prof: ce devoir d'ya, d'ya trois mois
euh c'était plus tôt pas, c'est bie.. je crois que.. oui tout le monde a eu vingt..
Tout le monde a vraiment eu vingt. un élève : j'ai pas rendu ma copie. Le prof : ferme ta gueule
vraiment on peut même s'applaudir, je pense, bravo. Applaudis !
c'est pas mal l'effort d'avoir mis une classe ect
d'avoir réparti les rôles
il y a juste la synchro sur la fin qui a laissé à désirer mais
gros effort, en perspective voilà je suis un prof de tiktok
J'évalue vos tiktok, c'est pas mal nan ? Faudrait que je sois payé pour ça
Par l'éducation national, s'il vous plait.
"Je comprends pas comment on a pu appeler des fruits de mer...
des fruits de mer... S'il y a bien un truc qui ressemble pas à un fruit c'est ça quoi."
Oh petit emoji crevette. "Y a quand même un mec qui s'est dit...
"Aaaah, on dirait un peu...une poire, c'est vrai."
Là je suis obligé de mettre une bonne note. C'est un 9/10 facile parce que
ya l'apparition de l'emoji, ya du montage, on est pas loin du Spielberg là.
Je vous vois tous regarder avec beaucoup d'envie ma coque crustacé faite avec Lucas
On a lancé la boutique Bigorneaux et Coquillages. Et vous pouvez commander les produits
Et tous les bénéfices iront à l'association CékeduBonheur qui va aider
et soutenir les enfants dans les hôpitaux. Crustacés, y a des T-shirts, et tout ça.
"Voix Cyprien : Pensez-vous que vos dents sont vraiment propres ? Voix Natoo : Oui bien sûr. Voix Cyprien : Vérifions ça"
"Voix Cyprien : Regardez. Voix Natoo : Des Bactéries ? Mais je me suis brossée les dents ce matin!"
"Voix Cyprien : Pas avec Colgate total. DANS LA VIE.
"Excusez-moi ?" "NON, est ce que je viens te faire chier dans la rue moi hein?
"Et en plus c'est pour me dire que j'ai les dents sales. Et ton cul, il est propre ? Ducon va."
Bravo, là y a carrément le petit panneau "Dans la vie", beaucoup de talent.
La perruque, au début j'ai cru que c'était une femme.
On est sur un degré de réalisme, c'est quelqu'un qui a fait les instagrammeuses qui dit ça attention.
"Excusez-moi ?" "NON, est ce que je viens te faire chier dans la rue moi hein?
"Et en plus c'est pour me dire que j'ai les dents sales. Et ton cul, il est propre ? Ducon va."
C'est génial que pleins de gens redisent cette réplique: "Et ton cul il est propre?" De Natoo
D'ailleurs petite exclusivité
ma prochaine vidéo ce sera: "Les Pubs Vs La Vie"
le nouvel opus.
Vous le gardez pour vous;
Oui j'ai plusieurs millions d'abonnés sur ma chaîne je demande de gardez pour vous...
Oui c'est un peu hypocrite je le reconnais.
On va faire un jeu:
je vais essayé de deviner la vidéo, juste avec la miniature.
Je pense que ça avec le truc rayé à droite et le béret,
je dirais que c'est... Les langues étrangères.
"Tu dis un ou une canapé?
Attends 'tends  "Yes!!" Tu as donné des genres aux objets?"
Superbe... Exécution
Mais je viens de voir un truc là: "Votre Youtuber préféré? Perso Sueezie et Amixem."
Mais je suis pas dedans.
Et les gens disent quoi dans les commentaires:
"Sora, Amixem" je trouve que y'a pas beaucoup mon prénom dans un truc
où c'est MA VIDEO QUAND MEME!!!
C'est pas grave...
Je ne fais pas ça pour la gloire
Je fais ça pour la beauté de l'art
"Et heu... Qui est ce qui porte le bébé? Bah l'homme hein! Vous êtes sûrs? Ça dure 9 mois c'est douloureux...
Ça laisse des vergetures et ça fait vomir...
La femme ouais la femme! C'est mieux ouais! "
C'est trop bien!!
Un truc où on fait tous les personnages je trouve ça vraiment fort, d'ailleurs je l'ai fait
récemment pour mon court métrage "Fais un vœu" du coup j'aime bien
le voir aussi chez les autres et de voir la voix d'Alison Wheeler qui va si bien!
J'adore.
"Ok maintenant tu restes appuyé sur ton visage...
et tu glisses sur la droite...
jusqu’à ce que tu vois le chien."
YA LE CHIEN !!!!
Trop bien !!! Trop trop bien !! 10 sur 10 ! Tout le monde sait à Hollywood
que c'est dur de tourner avec des chiens, c'est infernal
et bah voilà ! On refait le sketch, on reprend carrément les accessoires, tous les différents figurants
notamment le chien. Super !
"Impossible: s'énerver avec de l'hélium!
Non mais c'est pas bientôt fini ?! C'est n'importe quoi !! Faut tout refaire !!"
Je sais même pas d'où vient cet extrait... Aucune idée...
*musique angoissante*
Ok personne âgée, Alzheimer, tout va bien...
"Les propriétés de l'intégrale sont vraiment très importantes"
"Bonjour! Je suis un homme lambda, cadre d'entreprise..." Alors c'est très bizarre d'avoir ma voix
sur quelqu'un qui visiblement n'est pas un homme lambda.
D'ailleurs je pense qu'on a le même physique n'est ce pas regardez
On est pareil !
"Ya quelques jours j'ai été invité au mariage de ma cousine, le week-end prochain je dois aller à un mariage...
Oh c'est chiant ça..." Ah les gens passent derrière tranquillement.
"OH ! C'est trop stylé !" C'est marrant parce que je pensais pas que les gens allait reprendre
cette vidéo sur le mariage de ma cousine n'est ce pas...
J'ai l'impression qu'il y a des tik tok sur tout et n'importe quoi en fait
de mes vidéos, des extraits parfois qui n'ont aucun sens d'ailleurs peut-être que cette vidéo sera
dans un tik tok. Y aura peut-être un tik tok de gens qui disent ces phrases là.
Tik tik-ception.
Et oui...
Alors c'est quoi ça...
Ah c'est un sosie ! J'ai trouvé un sosie ! Ya quand même un petit truc. On découvre aussi des sosies
dans tik tok c'est quand même intéressant
"Sors un peu Cyprien ! Rentre à la maison !
Sors ! Rentre ! Sors ! Rentre ! (...) ça s'en va et ça revient !
Je redécouvre mes sketchs !
J'avais oublié que ça se terminait comme ça!
"Le roi Clovis Premier naît en quatre cent soi...
Monsieur excusez moi est ce que je peux poser une question s'il vous plaît ? Bien-sûr. Qui s'en bat totalement les couilles ici ?"
Cette personne fait très bien moi qui fait un prof d'histoire, si je puis me permettre
"Clovis premier" C'est un 10 sur 10.
Alors il faut que je vous dise un truc. Franchement ça me fait trop plaisir de voir
Bah j'sais pas c'est des sketchs, des vidéos que je fais depuis si longtemps
J'ai oublié carrément ce qu'il y avait dedans. Et de voir qu'en fait ya des gens
qui les reproduisent comme ça, si bien...
Et bah voilà, bravo à vous, c'est génial.
Alors moi j'aimerais faire un truc parce que je trouve qu'on a la critique facile, les gens se moquent
Est ce que c'est facile de faire un tik tok ?
"J'me plains pas avec mon corps, c'est juste que le mec qui a imaginé mon corps" Ok on va essayé de faire ça "avait perdu les plans !
Ok donc la je découvre toutes les vidéos qui utilisent le même extrait
Ok je découvre tik tok ! On est en 2018 ! Je suis une personne âgée !
Donc je vais la dessus... J’imagine que si je reste appuyé
Ok on va la faire au ralentis, on peut le faire ! Excusez moi c'est mon premier tik tok
de moi sur moi ok c'est une nouveauté, on n'a jamais vu ça. Tik tok-ception !
"J'me plains pas..."
Ok on a ça. La je change de tenue comme ça vous avez aussi le making-of de comment on fait un tik tok.
Hop, hop ceci est Hans
On découvre ! "J'me plains pas avec mon corps, c'est juste que le mec qui
a imaginé mon corps avait perdu les plans ! Il est parti en impro !"
"Je m'appelle Hans, je suis le créateur du corps de Cyprien.
Pour faire simple, j'ai fait n'importe quoi !"
Ah c'est nul !
Oh les gens sont meilleur que moi ! Oh j'ai honte !
"Mon premier tik tok...
J'ai honte car vous êtres meilleurs..."
Hashtags Cyprien, humour, passidouéqueça... Publier.
J'ai honte de ce tik tok qui est 100 fois moins bon que ceux des autres
J'suis tellement pas synchro putain jsuis nul mais vous êtres très bons.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo un petit peu spéciale
qui n'est pas un sketch, un court métrage ou ce genre de chose mais ça m'a fait très plaisir de partager ce moment avec vous.
Et petite surprise pour vous voilà c'est bientôt Noël, vous pouvez rejoindre mon tik tok ici
et moi je vais mettre pleins d'extraits de mes vidéos qui sont pas encore dessus
pour que vous puissiez les refaire, voilà vous pouvez vous éclater la dessus.
Ya pas de soucis, merci pour tous ces petits cadeaux que vous m'avez fait
en utilisant les extraits même si certains les ont... bon bref ya encore un peu de marge de progression
mais vous êtres quand même meilleurs que moi, merci beaucoup, je vous dit à très vite sur internet
Abonnez vous ;)